well 2020 is something else y'all
because tom bergeron
dropped a ballroom bombshell he is out
of dancing with the stars
and so is co-host aaron andrews
how much longer would you do dancing i
show up on
show day it's been a great surprise in
my career to have that show
15 years after tom first hosted season
one in 2005.
welcome to the very first episode of
dancing
tom broke the news himself he was not
asked to return next season
his rep tells e.t quote in the fine
tradition of hollywood cliches
they're going in a different direction
that appears to have been a big shock
for the host
abc also confirmed tom's sidekick of six
years aaron andrews is
also out can you confirm your back for
the fall i
honestly don't know anything they don't
tell me a thing
last season the show cut a bunch of
dancers including the popular artum in
sharna
in the wake of this shake up pros and
alums including bindi irwin
leah thompson and lance bass reacted
online
sasha farber said quote you are absolute
legends and we love you there's an old
saying
that the show must go on so what's next
season 29 is scheduled to return in the
fall although there is
no word yet on who will be the new host
et
has learned bachelorette caitlyn bristow
is set to compete
carriana naba told us big changes are
ahead
we've been around this long because we
try to evolve and keep up and keep it
fresh and interesting
hopefully we're coming back but we don't
know what the next few months look like
just kobe we're all sort of on pins and
needles trying to figure out what's
going to happen
there's another tv shake-up going on
over at the reel
you do your research about what you
bring to the table
tamira mori housley announced she's
leaving seven years after the show's
2013 debut
according to our e.t source they
couldn't come to an agreement on her
contract
it's not easy producing a talk show and
hosting a talk
i actually thought it was going to be a
lot easier
but i will say these ladies make it a
lot of fun the news comes a month after
former co-host amanda seals abruptly
announced her departure
after six months on the show i did not
renew it
because it doesn't feel good to my soul
tamira's announcement came as divers
discovered the body of her good friend
nya rivera
she said quote i had no intention to
talk about this today
but now some reports are coming out and
i'd rather you hear it from me first
now what you may not have known is that
tamara and her family
became close with naya when tamara's
brother taj worked with nya on the 90
series smart guy
tamara posted in part i knew as early as
nine years old you were going to grace
us with so much talent
and so much beauty you took my breath
away and always will